hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show here's what's making the news today
households are paid to use less energy
again for the second evening in a row as
a shortage in wind power stretches
supplies
the Pakistani prime minister apologizes
to the nation after a massive power cut
leaves Millions without drinking water
or electricity during harsh winter
weather
the charity buys 460 Acres of Somerset
Farmland as part of a plan to create a
nature reserve in all 48 English
counties by the middle of the century
foreign
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
now households will again be paid to
reduce their electricity usage tonight
as the National Grid warns of tighter
than usual electricity supplies the
demand flexibility scheme will run
between 4 30 and 6th this evening as
recent cold weather and a lack of wind
means generation from turbines has been
limited our Science and Technology
editor Tom Clark has been in Salford
looking at how future Smart Homes could
automatically reduce Demand on the grid
so I'm outside an aluminum sided
building could be anywhere in the world
what's it got to do with how we manage
electricity demand going into the future
well come inside and I'll show you
because this is Salford University's
future home lab
and inside
it's minus 15 degrees for starters to
simulate real world conditions
and it's big enough to house four
perfectly normal looking semi-detached
houses these are built to the Future
home standard of Energy Efficiency they
also tell us something about how we
might be managing demand in the future
so right now National Grid are right to
Consumers to ask them to switch off
appliances between half past four and
six o'clock but in future homes could do
that automatically this electric
vehicle's got 78 kilowatt battery that's
talking to the smart meter in the house
when grid demand is high and electricity
prices are highest the meter would know
that and the house would start drawing
power from the car battery instead of
from the grid saving the consumer money
and also saving pressure on the grid
inside it's totally warm and it's heated
by an air source heat pump that's what's
running these radiators now that's using
electricity in future we'll be putting
much higher electricity demand onto the
grid
but the air source heat pump also talks
to the smart meter the brain of the home
which is up in the loft
and again when demand is high the air
source heat pump can switch off for an
hour or two or even three because it's a
well-insulated home and it will stay
warm in order to make all this work we
need quite a lot of Reform of the
electricity Market there are pilots
ongoing but people will argue there's
quite a lot of work to do to see the
sort of tech in homes like this which
could be in many homes certainly new
build homes in the not too distant
future actually work
I think for the time being understand
here it's a lot more modern outside
and let's take a look now at some of the
other stories making the news today and
Pakistan's prime minister has apologized
to the nation after a major day-long
power cut left Millions without
electricity or running water during
harsh winter weather although power was
mostly restored earlier this morning it
is the second major blackout in just
five months and has led to harsh
criticism in the country writing on
Twitter Shabazz Sharif said on behalf of
my government I would like to express my
sincere regrets for the inconvenience
our citizens suffered due to power
outage yesterday on my orders and
inquiries underway to determine reasons
of the power failure Pakistan gets at
least 60 percent of its electricity from
fossil fuels and its depleted reserves I
mean it is almost entirely reliant on
Imports
the boss of the environment agency has
outlined his vision for future city
living in a speech earlier today sir
James Bevin argued that cities provide a
solution and not a cause of climate
change with more of us living in cities
than the countryside now he said that
the modern city should provide
convenient public transport walking and
cycling as the best way to get around
he's also argued that green space needs
to be better Incorporated incorporated
as sponges to deal with heavier rainfall
the German government is being sued over
its failure to meet its climate targets
Friends of the earth Germany say the
government should be forced to put
forward emergency programs to deal with
transport and building emissions two
sectors they say have fallen behind on
legally binding targets
a Brazilian police say they're planning
to indict a Colombian fish Trader as the
alleged Mastermind in last year's
killing of the British journalist Don
Phillips an indigenous expert Bruno
Pereira the pair were reporting in a
remote area of the Amazon when they were
killed the police alleged that Ruben
Dario de Silva Villar provided the
ammunition and made phone calls to a
fisherman who had earlier confessed to
shooting the men
the UK government is being urged to
support local communities in buying land
to plant trees a new report by Green
Alliance suggests that involving local
communities in nature restoration and
tree planting projects is crucial in
averting rural opposition to the land
use changes needed to combat the climate
crisis the environmental Think Tank
predicts that a third of England's tree
planting Target could be met with just
200 community-led projects
a rewilding charity has bought 460 acres
of land in Somerset to create what it
hopes will be the first of a series of
nature reserves in every English County
Hill was launched at the start of the
pandemic the new site costs over 5
million pounds it's near Bruton and the
charity says it will aim to tackle both
the nature and climate crises and could
possibly create new jobs and facilities
for the local community well joining me
now from the site in Somerset is heel
rewilding chief executive Jan Starr
there she is Jan hello to you thank you
so much for joining us on the climate
show so how is this going to work
hello Kimberly
um this is the first of our sites and it
will work by Nature leading the recovery
um to support
um a quiet space for wildlife and to
fight climate change in four ways so
rewilding which is the method that's
used to create this new Nature Reserve
um uh helps with climate mitigation in
in four ways so it's a really effective
way of uh of contributing to Something
That Matters to all of us
Jen what about the argument
um that quite a few make that actually
what we need is more agricultural land
and a focus on our long-term food
security
food security is obviously important to
all of us we're all in the food system
um but but one thing to consider is that
if you look at how England as a country
is doing in the world and you take all
the countries and territories we are in
234th place for the health of our nature
and that is languishing at the bottom
and we need to take action to address
that and if we put the site that we
bought in Somerset into context there
are 275 000 acres under agricultural use
in Somerset and this site is 0.07 of
that so it's a very very small
percentage but what nature needs is
sites of this scale that are peaceful
where nature can Thrive to act as a
reservoir to allow Wildlife to thrive
there and then spread out into the land
around it
it cost over 5 million pounds this
project where did you get that money
from
when we launched in March 2020 we knew
as a new charity that we would be very
unlikely to raise that much in donations
in a short time and we're in the middle
of a crisis both nature and climate so
to move quickly we've been supported
wonderfully supported by lots of uh
people who've given us donations but
also by triados Bank UK and by direct
line group who have both given us loans
to enable us to acquire this site and we
will then be working over the coming
years to pay down those loans and to
begin to develop the site for for nature
and for
um certain numbers of visitors and you
have plans to roll this out more widely
how long is that going to take and where
are you planning to take this
okay so the next site is planned for the
north of England we wanted there to be a
balance across the country and then
after that uh we'll look at every County
and we've said 2050 25
000 Acres or so by 2050 so I'm in my
mid-60s I may not see that but the
reason it's a charity is so that that
can continue
um so yeah middle of the century would
be an amazing achievement but sooner if
we can get the backing and what's the
response been like from the local
community of this current project
we've had three uh community events
where we've met the local community last
night we met about 70 people in the
village hall before that we had an open
morning we've met our neighbors before
we announced and there's been incredible
enthusiasm from lots of people but as
anywhere there is a mixture of views so
some people who are from the farming
Community are understandably concerned
about the change but others are really
welcoming and
um yes so we're really pleased with all
the messages of support that we've had
okay Jen thanks again for talking to us
thank you very much
right now before we go just a reminder
that the climate Show with Tom Heap is
on Saturday and Sunday at 3 30 and 7 30.
there you go that's all from us today
we'll be back in at 3 30 tomorrow see
you then
[Music]